costume trois pièces moustache
impeccable et démarches savamment étudié
cette élégance à l'ancienne c'est la clé
du succès de guillaume ii bernadac à
shanghai
sow aurier today ya bien que burger son
métier professeur de savoir vivre à la
française
cela fait cinq ans qu'ils enseignent aux
chinois et ce dès le plus jeune âge sow
can you remind me produce cette donne
please
ces enfants sont âgés de 4 à 12 ans mais
il n'est apparemment jamais trop tôt
pour apprendre à bien se tenir quitte à
souffrir un peu tant qu'ils se tiennent
bien droit ça ne va pas le faire mal et
de vous rien sentir mais s'il commence à
à s'avachir là ils vont sentir une
petite tension donc c'est un bon
exercice pour garder ses épaules en
arrière
la leçon du jour comment boire le thé
avec classe pas si facile quand on est
encore qu'une toute petite fille espère
got
et festive et du canal est le cas de la
ressourcerie
simply red
bull
rejettent
la culture chinoise donc on boit
beaucoup de thé notamment à ces jeunes
donc ils ont une manière qui différente
de la nôtre faty l'ont dit ils ont des
tailles différentes qui n'ont pas deux
ans notamment et ce seront des toute
petite tu as vraiment tout petit donc
c'est juste des gorges est donc ce n'est
pas on ne garde pas autant de liquide
est dans l'impasse tu crois que tout ça
te servira un jour
oui quand j'aurai un dîner où il nous
fait ça servirait à montrer mon élégance
et ma bonne éducation
car pour les chinois la france reste le
symbole absolu du raffinement et du
style ses parents n'auraient d'ailleurs
pas imaginer un professeur d'une autre
nationalité
je pense que les bonnes manières ont été
inventés par la noblesse française
et donc pour apprendre à ma fille à bien
se tenir je me suis dit qu'il fallait
absolument un professeur français
dans huit jours ses enfants passeront
même un examen mais l'excellence à la
française à un prix plus de 1000 euros
pour 2 heures de cours par semaine
pendant deux mois
rien n'est trop beau pour cette nouvelle
génération de chinois dans cette ville
qui s'ouvre au monde il y a cinq ans il
était étudiant en commerce ici à
l'université tanji l'une des plus
grandes du pays c'est en discutant avec
ses camarades chinois que l'idée lui est
venue le jeune adolescent posé beaucoup
de questions sur à l'avenir si j'allais
6 à l'étudiant en france comment est-ce
qu'on se faisait à bize comment on
allait manger à table comment on se
faisait des amis guillaume décident
d'exploiter cette curiosité pour les
habitudes françaises et pour parfaire sa
formation il n'a pas besoin d'aller
chercher bien loin il peut compter sur
son héritage familial
la petite histoire c'était que c'était
mon arrière grand père et mon arrière
grand oncle qui avait été
instituteur et les tuteurs à la cour du
maroc dans les années dans les années 20
il en citant les mathématiques le
français que des souvenirs de se
comporter être poli voilà par la suite
ma grand mère y est et n'est donc il a
passé ses premières années et c'est
grâce à elle c'est par elle que que j'ai
reçu cette passion pour le pour le
savoir vivre à la française une passion
qu'il transmet aujourd'hui aux adultes
de chinois soucieux d'améliorer leurs
connaissances des manières occidentales
english talent de fox avatar
en france talent
dans ce club très sélect de shanghai
guillaume ii bernadac dispense un cours
particulièrement prisés les arts de la
table
le plus grand armé de son
impressionnante collection de couverts
monsieur le professeur peut débuter les
travaux pratiques
tu es soit
le fromage le nord les fruits non aux
hipsters
oui 18
30 au bar de swann celle là c'est pour
les raviolis
ishow leucate est je tiens ces blocs nos
pour la sauce
une paire de baguettes une cuillère et
c'est tout c'est simple
cette journée de cours est facturé 850
euros par personne et malgré ce tarif le
succès du français ne se dément pas car
guillaume répond exactement aux attentes
de la clientèle chinoise ces gens là ont
une image assez conair onirique même de
notre culture donc elles veulent aussi
un peu rêver donc on le sait un peu ce
qu'on leur offre d'abord un peu accès le
temps d'une journée à quelques moments
un peu sophistiqué ou allons vivre un
peu le luxe à la française où il venait
de tuer ilkhan style it
c'est possible
battue qu'à not what you cannot au
podium
les clientes de guillaume son chef
d'entreprise banquière ou femme au foyer
contrairement à leurs aînés elles ont la
possibilité de voyager à l'étranger et
pour s'intégrer non non je note une
flotte ok elles sont prêtes à faire des
efforts
comment vous mangeriez à la chinoise
juste décontracté
champel okoumi volontiers un temps
pour les élèves en culottes courtes de
guillaume c'est le grand jour
sermonnés
d'animation
est trop grave les parents ont tous fait
le déplacement pour assister à l'examen
de fin d'année un examen couronné par
une épreuve périlleuse se déplacer avec
grâce la culotte
[Musique]
ce programme aura coûté plus de 1000
euros
à ce prix là malgré quelques faux pas
tout le monde gagne à la fin les iphones
des diplômes qui font la fierté des
parents car tout ce rêve d'envoyer leurs
enfants étudier à l'étranger
son grand frère fait déjà ses études aux
états unis je me suis aperçu qu'il avait
beaucoup évolué en termes de caractère
de morale et de connaissances depuis
qu'il est là bas quant à ma fille elle
souhaite devenir créatrice de mode je
l'enverrai aussi à l'étranger
ces cours depuis serviront ils
l'aideront à s'intégrer dans la société
locale à se faire des amis et bien
d'autres choses
les bogies juan frigo le chao sur un
frigo on espère leur donner plus de code
plus de clés pour pouvoir peut-être
s'intégrer facilement dans nos sociétés
plus facilement
c'est moi réussir chez nous aussi je
pense que j'ai encore beaucoup de
travail ici en chine là encore beaucoup
à faire
des perspectives professionnelles qui
vont retenir guillaume ici pour
plusieurs années avec ses business
potentiel shanghai la trépidante attire
toujours plus de français il y à 25 ans
ils étaient cent aujourd'hui ils sont
près de 20000